نعزي
نعزي انفسنا ونعزيكم في وفاه ابو خالد
رحمه الله عليها عبد القادر
عبد الكريم الله يرحمه ما وصل لهذا
المستوى الا حبه للتجديد
وحبه الى كل فنان ملحن يطلع جديد
والا لما وصل الى ما وصل اليه يعني زملائه
توقفوا من زمان
ولكن عبد الكريم ابتدا مع عبد الرحمن
البعيجان
فنان ناشئ وملحن نشط فعمل معاه تكون ظالم
يعني الزوار بعدين
لكن بدايته وانتشاره في تكون ظالم نجحت
نجاح كبير وما كرر هذا اللون من الاغاني
ما كرره بتاتا عملها بس بعد الاغنيه هذه
ومن ثم عمل الاستاذ احمد باقرى الليل يا
قمرنا ولا جيت في سهرنا وبعدين استمر مع
عبد الرحمن البعيجان ما يمنع انه اخذ من
المصطفى العوضي لحن من ابراهيم الصوله لحن
من سعود الراشد لحن فرديه شذي بس ولكن
الى ان طلع فنان جديد اسمه عبد الرب ادريس
كان وقتها ابو عادل دكتور عبد الرب ادريس
توه متخرج من المعهد وفنان شاب نشط
فالتقى معاه عن طريق الشاعر عبد اللطيف
البنايه وعملوا اغنيه
اول اغنيه طبعا اللي عاشق واذا صبري يطول
مسك عبد الكريم في عبد الرب ادريس واشتغل
معه قال هذا الان الحصان الجديد اللي يركض
في الساحه فعمل معه غريب واحترف لك
وباختصار مجموعه من الاغاني بعدها طلع
راشد الخضر رحمه الله عليه توام متخرج من
المعهد فنان شاب وكذلك عن طريق عبد اللطيف
البناي كذلك ما ننسى
على طول جماعها مع بعض وعملوا حبيبي يزعل
من الصبر اخر ومجموعه الاغاني الجميله هذه
حلوه في هذه الفتره طلع انور عبد الله
تخرج من المعهد
واجتمعنا مع انا معاه في اغنيه
وانا اذكر موقف الى الان يمكن ما قلته في
كل مقاباتي
نشتغل اول اغنيه وهي اغنيه رياضيه
بنادي الخليج في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
كان وقتها فايز في كاس اليد عبد اللطيف
البناي قال له والله في يوم الاحد نسمع
انور توه طالع وكذا كذا كذا خل نشتغل فقال
اوكي فقعدنا مع
بعضيه قال لي عبد الله كيف الحال حياك
الله وكذا هذا انا بسمع اللحن عجبني غنيته
ما عجبني انا اعتذر من الان وهي اغنيه
رياضيه وفعلا سمعت اللحن وقال يلا خل نسجل
يعني شنو الاستديو شافني انا مرتبك
ايه
انا مرتبك ليش لانه قدامي هامه كبيره
هرم من اهرامات الاغنيه الخليجيه وانا
توني في بدايتي في بدايه طريقي
فقال استاذ انور قلت له والله ما فيني شيء
قلت كل ما اقول شيء اغني تقول حلو كل ما
اقول شيء تقول حلو ما عندك ملاحظات
مرتبك
قال استاذ انور انا اقولك من البدايه هنا
في الاستديو والله العظيم
احنا في الاستوديو انت الاستاذ
وانا المطرب فانا اتلقى توجيهاتك شنو اللي
تقول انا اقول شوف شوف الموقف من فنان
الكبير
وابتدينا في هذه الاغنيه
الرياضيه ومن ثم انتقلنا الى اغنيه الى
مين الشيخ محمد بن راشد ال مكتوم ومن ثم
بدينا في محال
واستمرت الاغاني هذه الى الحمد لله لي
الشرف وهذا وسام على صدري انا احطه اني
انا لحنت له 45 اغنيه
اعتبر اكثر ملحن في حياه عبد الكريم عبد
القادر
وهذا وسام على صدري
طيب يعني احنا خلينا نقول بانه انور عبد
الله علاقتك مختلفه مع مع الفنان عبد
الكريم عبد القادر ابي اقول في في السنوات
الاخيره
وشركه عبد الكريم ليش ما يطلع على المسرح
شو اللي يخليه مبتعد عن عن المسرح
عبد الكريم من زمان ما طلع المسرح
والسبه يعني كذا موقف صار
عبد الكريم ما يحب الاوامر عبد الكريم ما
يحب واحد ايوه ما يحب واحد يقول يلا غني
يلا وقف خلفان يغني بعدين انت غني ما يحب
شذي بعدين عبد الكريم ما يحب السهر وبعدين
عبد الكريم فنان حساس الى ابعد الحدود ما
ممكن تتصور شلون ابو خالد حساس جدا جدا
وحليم لكن من داخله يغني ولكن ما يبين لك
ولا اشي بتاتا انت لما تقعد في حفلات سواء
حفلات عامه ولا حفلات اجتماعيه وكذا مثلا
يلا غني يلا غني اغنيه كذا كذا بعد شوي
غني ما احب شذي بعدين ما يحبوه هو يغني في
الحفلات ناس يقولون يرقصون ولا كذا مدري
شنو ما يحب اذا هو يغني بهذا القرار رحمه
الله انه يبتعد عن الحفلات شكرا للملحن
انور عبد الله ابو عبد الله شكرا جزيلا لك
واعلم هذه المحبه الصادقه في كلماتك
ومشاعرك شكرا جزي لا للملحن انور عبد الله
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات